STEVE HINDY: Thank you
all for coming today.
I suppose this is not a bad
way to spend the afternoon
at Google, having
a couple of beers
and listening to me talk
about my book a little.
So what I'm going to
do is outline for you
the book hopefully talking about
some interesting stories that
are in the book.
I want to say upfront that I am
the founder of the co-founder
of the Brooklyn
Brewery since 1988.
And the reason I think I'm
qualified to write such a book
is I've gotten to know
most of the pioneers
and founders of the whole
craft beer movement.
And I've been involved
in it pretty intimately
from the beginning through
our association, the Brewer's
Association.
And like many of my generation
of craft brewery, people
who started in the
1980s, I had a career
before I got into
the beer business.
I was a journalist.
I graduated from college
in the early '70s.
I had a degree in English, and
I tried teaching high school
and almost had a
nervous breakdown.
It was the hardest thing
I ever did in my life,
teaching senior English
to the bright class
and the dumb class.
Both of them were
terrifying for me.
I was never the most
well behaved student.
And as a teacher it seemed
like every day was payback
for the way I treated my
teachers back in the day.
So I realized I couldn't teach.
And so I got a job at the
newspaper in upstate New York,
and I worked for small
newspapers for a couple years.
And I got my big chance job
with the Associated Press
in Newark, New Jersey in 1976.
And for reasons I usually go
into after I've had about four
beers, I got in my head
I wanted to cover a war.
And if you work for
AP you can do that.
So I started studying Arabic and
said, I want to go to Beirut.
And I learned there
aren't too many people who
want to go to Beirut
and cover wars.
So like a year
after I volunteered,
I landed in Beirut as the Middle
East correspondent for AP.
That was February, '79 when
the shah was being overthrown
in Iran and Ayatollah
Khomeini was coming to power.
So I went to Iran and
covered the tail end
of the revolution and
the hostage crisis.
I know many of you
are very young.
But you know the movie, "Argo?"
It's that period.
So I was in Iran for that.
I got thrown out of Iran
eventually by the government.
I went back into Iran the
next year with the Iraqi army
when they invaded Iran.
I covered that war
from the Iraqi side.
And I don't know if any
of you served in Iraq.
But if you know anything about
working with the Iraqi army,
it's pretty exciting.
I lived in Beirut.
In Beirut we had the
civil war ongoing.
And eventually the
Israeli invasion, the
massacres in the refugee
camps, Sabra and Shatila.
I covered those stories.
Moved to Cairo, and I was
sitting behind President Sadat
when he was killed at
the parade in 1981.
So I covered a lot
of big stories.
It was actually
pretty good training
for starting a
brewery in Brooklyn.
I'm not kidding.
But when I was in Cairo,
I met American diplomats
who had worked in Saudi Arabia.
They had three year
postings in Saudi Arabia.
And Saudi Arabia has
pretty strict prohibition
on alcoholic beverages.
So these guys were
avid home brewers.
They'd gotten into
home brewing in Saudi,
and they continued in Egypt
because the beer in Egypt
was not very good.
It was reputed to have a little
dose of formaldehyde in it
as a preservative.
And you could feel
your lips getting
a little numb after the first
few sips of Egyptian beer.
So these guys made
home brewed beer.
And then my wife, who was with
me through not the whole thing,
but much of my years
in the Middle East,
we had our first child.
Actually, Sam was born
in Beirut during the war.
Lily, our daughter,
was born in Cairo.
And AP wanted me to
go to the Philippines
next because President
Marcos was in trouble.
And I was a conflict
reporter, that's what I did.
I was really excited about this.
And my wife said, no.
I'm not taking the kids
to the Philippines.
I'm going back to New York.
I hope you come with me.
But if not, have a nice life.
So I gave it up and
came back to New York
and went to work for News Day
doing foreign news for Newsday,
living in Brooklyn and making
beer at home, home brewing.
And eventually with my
downstairs neighbor,
Tom Potter, who was a
young guy with an MBA
who'd always wanted to
start his own business,
I convinced him that it was
not a completely lunatic thing
to try to start a brewery.
And we started Brooklyn Brewery.
That was 1988 when we
sold our first beer.
I count myself among
what I call in the book,
the first generation
of craft brewers.
And that's different
than the pioneers.
The pioneers I describe
as a period from 1965
when Fritz Maytag from the
Maytag washing machine fortune,
bought an old failing brewery in
San Francisco called the Anchor
Brewing Company and brought
back Anchor Steam beer, which
was a particular kind of beer,
a lager beer actually brewed
at warmer temperatures
like an ale
to produce this special
style called steam.
And a lot of
different explanations
of where steam came from had
to do with the era of steam
engines or when you tap the keg
you got a little puff of steam
off the beer.
But you get that off any beer.
But anyway, enough of that.
So Fritz was the first
guy to bring back
traditionally brewed beer.
So 100$ Malta barley, no rice
or corn like the big brewers.
And he was alone in
this pursuit until 1978.
And there was a guy
named Jack McAuliffe who
had been in the US
Navy based in Scotland.
He was a submariner.
And he got into home brewing
when he was in Scotland.
And in England, that was in UK,
that was the era of real ale
and the campaign for real
ale which was a movement
to preserve the traditional
style of brewing and serving
ale in England.
So Jack is a real entrepreneur,
a very quirky personality.
Jack started New Albion
Brewery in Sonoma.
And that was really the
first home built brewery.
So it was made out of
cobbled together parts.
Soda, Pepsi tanks,
and dairy tanks
and all that sort of thing.
And actually, his two
partners were Jane Zimmerman,
and I'm spacing on the
name of the second one.
But it was two women.
And they were intimately
involved in brewing the beer.
Actually one of them was
intimately involved with Jack,
but that's a different story.
But they made the first
beer, New Albian Ale.
And Susie Dennison
was the second woman.
They made New Albian Ale.
And that was really kind of
the first built from the ground
up brewery, very different
than Fritz Maytag
who-- I always
felt Fritz was kind
of playing with a
different sheet of music
than the rest of us, because
he had a fortune behind him.
Jack did not, but that only
lasted about six years.
But it had a huge impact
on several important people
like Ken Grossman
from Sierra Nevada,
Paul Shipman from Red Hook.
Actually, I was
talking to John Hall
from Goose Island
in Chicago recently,
and he told me he
visited New Albian also.
So a lot of people who were
home brewing at that time
kind of flocked to
New Albian and were
inspired from what Jack and
his partners were doing.
Actually, I remember Ken
Grossman saying something
like, you know,
what Jack was doing
was just kind of a glorified
home brewing operation.
So Ken started his
brewery in Chico
in a garage basically
cobbling things together
the same way Jack had done.
And it was a period
of struggling
to sell this stuff
because nobody
knew what craft beer was.
It was called
microbrewed beer then.
Actually, that term
microbrewery came
from a guy who was working
for Charlie Papazian.
And Charley Papazian is the
founder of the Great American
Beer Festival and "Zymurgy"
magazine-- how many of you
are home brewers, by the way?
Oh shit, you know all
this stuff, right?
Well, stop me if I'm
get too detailed here.
But actually, there
was a guy working
for Charlie who was
a software engineer.
And he coined the
term, "microbrewery."
He basically said to Charlie
at one point, these people
starting these small
breweries, they're
kind of like microprocessors.
These are microbreweries.
And that's where
that term came from.
And it endured
for quite a while.
Today, we call a
microbrewery a brewery
that's making fewer than
15,000 barrels a year.
And actually, it's a
very fast growing segment
of craft beer now in America.
Fritz talks about the early
days about how difficult it
was to sell the
beer because people
just didn't understand
what he was doing.
They thought he was crazy.
They thought he was from
Mars or something like that.
And he talked about how they
had to dump a lot of beer.
Because they would
brew the beer,
but they couldn't sell
it quickly enough.
And it would go bad, so they'd
have to dump it down the sewer.
And that's a very painful
thing for any brewer to do,
I can tell you.
There is an interesting
story about Red Hook which
I think illustrates a
lot of the way things
were back with the pioneers.
Red Hook Brewery
in Seattle, started
by Paul Shipman who
was a wine salesman.
Shipman was
determined that he was
going to brew really
original beer.
So he didn't want to
use any brewer's yeast
from any of the institutions
that catalog different yeast,
so he got a yeast
from a professor
at the University of Washington,
and they made Red Hook Ale.
And they set a date
for the opening
of the brewery in
Seattle at a pub.
And a few days
before the opening
they realized the beer really
didn't taste very good.
It was off.
But they had
committed to the date
and it had been in the press.
So they forged ahead.
They had the big day with the
mayor, and all the politicians,
and a lot of dignitaries.
They tapped the keg,
they poured the beer.
Everyone tasted the
beer and kind of looked
at each other like, oh
yeah, this is great.
But they knew it really wasn't.
And leave it to the journalist--
there was a reporter there
from the Seattle newspaper
who wrote what everyone was
thinking which is, this
tastes likes rotten bananas.
This is not the
way it should be.
But Shipman, like
any entrepreneur,
was very determined.
And he forged ahead
with this beer.
And for about a year
they kind of limped along
selling this beer that people
were excited about because they
loved the idea of a local
brewery there in Seattle.
But they all knew it
didn't taste very good.
And the feedback they were
getting from their customers
was people order
one pint of this,
then they kind of
drink half of it.
Then they order Coors
Light for the next beer.
But Shipman was determined.
So Michael Jackson came to town.
And I hope, I'm sure as home
brewers, you all know who,
which Michael Jackson
I'm talking about here.
I'm talking about
the British beer
writer who was incredibly
influential for their craft
beer movement in America
and all over the world,
for that matter.
His "1977 World Guide to
Beer" made experts of myself
and many of you, I'm sure.
Michael did incredible
research into brewing,
and visited virtually every
brewery on the planet.
And Michael never said anything
bad about any craft brewery.
He was the total supporter
of the movement in the US.
So he came to Seattle and
he tasted the Red Hook Beer.
And of course, there
was great anticipation.
This is Michael Jackson
tasting my beer.
So Michael swirled it around.
And he said, this is kind
of like a Belgian beer.
And Shipman, the ultimate
salesman said, exactly Michael.
It's a Belgian style beer.
So they changed all
the copy on their label
to say it's a Belgian style
beer and all the marketing copy.
It's like, we've got this
great Belgian style beer.
But still, the stuff
was not selling well.
Then another guy came to
town who actually turned out
to be a very important man
in the history of craft beer,
named Joe Owades.
Joe Owades is a brewing
chemist who-- he died,
I think last year--
most famous for-- he's
the father of light beer.
He created diet beer at the
Rheingold Brewery in Brooklyn,
I think in the '60s.
And the marketing
geniuses at Rheingold
named the beer
"Gablingers," which
is not the most appetizing
name for a beer.
And it totally flopped.
It wasn't until Miller
Lite in the '70s and '80s
got into marketing light
beer that light beer really
took off.
But Joe was the
guy who created it.
And he's a brewing chemist.
A very natty dresser
with a pencil
mustache, very German, very
blunt, and iconoclastic.
So Owades came to Seattle.
And at the time, he
was teaching brewing
at Anchor in San Francisco.
He had a program there.
So he came to Seattle and
he tasted the Red Hook Ale.
And he turned to Paul
Shipman and said,
is this made for some
unusual ethnic group
here in Seattle or something?
And Shipman, the ultimate
salesman, is like, no Joe.
This is our Belgian style ale.
And Owades looks at him
and says no, it's not.
It's infected.
Let me show you
how to make beer.
And he advised them
on a yeast to buy
from a Siebel
Institute in Chicago.
And they changed the yeast.
They renamed the beer "Ballard
Bitter," and Red Hook took off.
I love that story because
it kind of describes
what it was like being a
pioneer with this whole thing
and trying to do
something original
and failing, but
pushing ahead with it,
and eventually, figuring it out.
Also, the involvement
of Michael Jackson.
Michael was so important in this
whole craft beer revolution.
We did many, many
events with Michael
here in New York in the '80s.
And he did so much to
educate people about beer
and laid the groundwork
for this whole thing.
And Owades, Owades eventually
consulted for many, many craft
brewers, including us
at Brooklyn Brewery.
He actually wrote the recipe
for Sam Adams Boston Lager.
It was based on Jim Koch's
family, his grandfather's
recipe.
But Joe was the guy who
actually put it together.
I think he worked at Sierra.
He worked at many breweries
over there as a consultant
because he was a real expert,
really interesting guy.
I was at a dinner at
Anchor several years ago
that Fritz Maytag threw, and
I was sitting next to Joe
on my left.
On my right was Gary Fish
from Deschutes Brewery.
And Gary's one of my closest
friends in the beer business.
And Gary's flagship brand
was Black Butte Porter,
which of course-- a dark beer.
And I knew that Joe
didn't like dark beer.
But I said Joe, you've got
to try Gary's porter here.
And Joe said, I don't
care for dark beer.
And I said, I know.
But Joe, this is Gary's
number one brand.
This is his flagship
there in Oregon.
And Owades looked
at me and said, yes,
and some people
like burnt toast.
You can't make up
these characters.
So my generation were
inspired by the likes
of Sierra Nevada, and Red
Hook, and these breweries
mostly out west.
There were only a
couple in the east.
There was Newman's Albany
Amber up in Albany.
I don't know if any
of you remember that.
One of you does.
Yeah.
Bill Newman made incredible
beer, just fantastic beer.
But I swear, he couldn't
sell water to a starving man.
He was a terrible salesman.
Then here in New York City
there was Matthew Reich
with New Amsterdam, a beer that
was actually also created along
with Joe Owades.
And New Amsterdam was
the first, actually
they were way ahead of
everybody back in the '80s.
Way ahead of Sam Adams,
way ahead of everyone.
And Matthew was the guy who
started contract brewing,
the concept of contract brewing.
He made his beer at
the Utica Brewery
up in Utica, New York where
we actually started out too.
When I started with
Brooklyn Brewery,
there was a reporter from
Manhattan Ink magazine
that called up Matthew.
And by this time he had
built an incredible brewery
on 11th Avenue and 26th
Street in the city,
and the reporter
asked Matthew what
he thought of this
Brooklyn Brewery project.
And Matthew said, I hope those
guys fall flat on their faces.
They've stolen every idea I
ever had, which is kind of true.
We all learned from the
people who came before us.
That's the way the
whole thing got built.
And Jim Koch with Sam Adams
learned a lot from Matthew.
And Jim of course,
contract brewed
at the beginning of
his company also.
And that was the way it
was back in the '80s.
We all were kind of focused on
making all malt beer and pretty
traditional styles
like an amber ale,
an amber lager, a porter,
a stout, often promoting
the idea that we're making
bitter by the Reinheitsgebot,
the German purity
law, only using
the four basic
ingredients of beer.
And those were sort
of the hallmarks
of my generation starting out.
The '90s were just a
crazy time for craft beer.
A lot of money came in,
a lot of venture capital.
It was the dot com years.
A lot of venture capital came
into the brewing industry
as well as the tech industry.
There were like six or seven
companies that went public.
Only one of them
really succeeded
and that's Boston
Beer, Sam Adams.
All the others in
one way or another
screwed up as public companies.
And I think the reasons were
that they were too small.
They were too young
really to be committing
to the kind of
reporting that you have
to do as a public company
and the demands of the market
once you're a public company.
So the only one that
succeeded was Sam Adams.
The big brewers started
to aggressively attack
craft breweries
including-- Anheuser-Busch
really went after Sam
Adams in a big way
in the '90s with television
ads calling them out
for making contract
brewed beer and saying
they're fake breweries, they
don't really have breweries.
So a lot of stuff happened.
A lot of those ones
that went public tanked.
And the growth of
craft beer really
slowed down in the mid '90s.
And the press
basically was saying
this whole microbrewed
beer thing is over.
And a lot of people bought it.
Actually, a lot
of craft brewers,
if you talk to them about the
'90s, will say the same thing.
The interesting thing I
uncovered in writing this book
is that far from a
time of retrenchment,
the craft brewing
movement really
laid the groundwork for the
next explosion of craft beer
during that period.
Between '94 and I
think 2000, there
were like 1,000
breweries started.
And it was a period of
incredible innovation.
New Belgium Brewery
in Colorado started up
making only Belgian style beers.
Allagash up in Maine
started up, Stone
in San Diego, Russian
River in California,
Dog Fish in Delaware.
And these were all very
creative, very inventive,
very innovative
brewers and breweries.
Garrett Oliver
joined us in 1994.
And the first beer he
did for Brooklyn brewery
was Brooklyn Black
Chocolate Stout.
Garrett had been the founder of
the New York City Home Brewer's
Guild.
I met in 1986.
He was working for big law firm.
He quit and went to work
for Manhattan Brewery, which
was the first brew
pub in the city.
And he learned to brew there.
Manhattan Brewery failed
under three different owners.
It was like the second owner
was dumber than the first owner,
and the third was
the dumbest of all.
They had great beer, they
had a great location.
But they just couldn't
put it all together.
And it really was poor
leadership, I think.
But Garrett learned
to brew there.
He joined us.
And actually, they
were in bankruptcy
when Garrett brewed the first
Brooklyn Black Chocolate
Stout at the Manhattan
Brewery, and no one
was paying any attention
to what he was doing.
He had the grain
and he could do it.
And Garrett talks about
that as his resume
for Brooklyn Brewery.
So that was the
first beer for us.
The second Garrett did was
Brooklyn East India Pale
Ale, which is a very balanced
IPA which of course, it's still
one of our big
selling our brands.
And that eventually led
to the Belgian style
beers that we make and the wheat
beers, and the incredible range
that we now produce in Brooklyn.
So when people talk about
the '90s, craft beer almost
disappeared, they're really
wrong because there was so much
new energy coming into
the craft beer world.
At that time that you just
can't understate how important
the '90s were for
laying the groundwork
for the future of craft beer.
So I don't buy
the shakeout idea.
There were some
spectacular failures.
Pete's Wicked Ale went like
this, to 400,000 barrels,
and then went down almost
as quickly as it came up.
Catamount, up in
Vermont, which was
one of the pioneer, one of
the my generation of brewers,
failed.
They built a second brewery
and did not continue to grow,
so they had taken a lot of debt
to build that second brewery.
They didn't grow, so they
got squeezed had to sell.
Actually, Harpoon in Boston
bought the Catamount Brewery
back then.
And then there
were several things
that happened that
really supercharged
the whole movement.
In the last five
years, craft beer
has grown at a very
vigorous double digit pace.
Brooklyn Brewery has
actually grown at 25% pace.
In 2008 we sold 75,000
barrels of beer.
Last year we sold
220,000 barrels.
So we tripled during
that five year period.
And the same as happened to
a lot of craft breweries.
There were several reasons
why that happened, I think.
Number one was the distributors.
The big distributors in America
opened up to craft beer.
For many years the only
choices we had as craft brewers
when we're sell--
well, Brooklyn, we
distributed our own
beer for 15 years
because none of the big
distributors in New York City
were interested in us.
And believe me, I had no love
of running a trucking company
in New York City.
But we kind of have to do it.
And the only choice we
had going into new markets
was the Miller distributor,
or the Coors distributor,
or a wine distributor for whom
beer is like second class,
or a craft beer distributor of
which there weren't too many.
We were one.
And we knew because we were one
that craft beer distributors
didn't have the
capital to make it go.
And the whole
Anheuser-Busch network
of distributors,
for the most part
only carried
Anheuser-Busch products.
So that's like 50% of the
US market of distribution,
is Anheuser-Busch.
And we had no access to
that distribution network.
In the '90s, August
Bush declared
a policy of 100% share of mind.
So he said to his distributors,
if you only sell AB products,
I will give you
financial incentives,
and I'll make you rich.
Which he did actually,
and most of them
stuck to the 100% share of mind.
But that all fell apart
in the last 10 years
as craft beer began to grow and
mainstream beer began to lag.
And the Anheuser-Busch network
opened up to craft beer.
So it used to be when
we go into a new market,
we would prepare
this big presentation
and go to a distributor
and tell them
how we were going to sell the
beer, Brooklyn beer for them,
how we were going to make
them rich by putting salesmen
in their market,
doing promotions.
So basically we were trying
to sell ourselves to them.
After Anheuser-Busch,
distributors
opened up to craft beer.
Suddenly, I had competition
between the Miller-Coors people
and the Anheuser-Busch,
and the wine guys.
And now when we go
into a new market
the distributors
are presenting to us
and telling us
what they're going
to do for us if we pick
them for that market.
So it's hard to describe
how important that was.
There's still a lot of
problems between craft brewers
and distributors,
don't get me wrong.
But that's been very important
for the surge of craft beer
in the last 10 years.
Another big thing,
and I probably
don't have to tell you
all this, is social media
has been so important
for craft brewers.
Daniel Bradford, who's
the editor, the publisher
of "All About Beer" magazine,
he was the publisher
of "Zymurgy," the home brew
magazine back in the '80s.
And Daniel told me
back then he did
a survey of all the
readers of "Zymurgy."
And he found that 80%
of them had PCs at home.
And this was in the '80s.
Computers weren't
so common back then.
But home brewers were
definitely computer savvy.
And that whole
splintering of the media
and the emergence
of social media
has been absolutely
critical for craft brewers.
And it's been a big problem
for the big brewers.
For years they were able
to lock up the US market
by their domination of the
three big television networks.
But all that is gone,
it doesn't work anymore.
And the big guys haven't
really figured out
how to communicate
in this new world.
And it kind of
shows in and what's
happening with their sales too.
They've lost an
incredible volume
of sales in the last five years.
At the end of this
year I think it'll
be about 20 million
barrels, which is about 10%
of the whole US beer market.
And during that
same time, craft has
been on this tear,
growing double digits
the whole segment.
So you can't overstate the
importance of social media.
You can start a
little brewery today.
And people are doing this
in the middle of nowhere.
And the beer drinkers
will know more about you
than maybe you know about
yourself because they're
so into this and following
what's happening.
It's really quite amazing.
And this is happening
all over the world.
There are craft
breweries opening up
in a lot of places
around the world
because many-- the world
is hooked on light lager
beer the way America
was for many years.
And another important thing--
and it's hard to overstate this
too-- is our association,
the Brewer's Association,
you'll hear a lot of people
say that craft brewers are
really collegial.
That they cooperate
with each other,
that they work with
each other, that it's
kind of this unusual
situation where competitors
get together and work together
to build the category.
But it's really true.
And I attribute it to two
thing-- the Great American Beer
Festival and the Craft
Brewer's Conference.
It brings us
together every year.
And I have friends, brewer
friends all over the country.
We come together, we
talk about our problems.
We talk about experiences,
we trade war stories.
And I've learned so much
from people like Gary Fish
at Deschutes or Kim Jordan
at New Belgium, another one
of my really close friends.
It really is a very collegial
atmosphere in craft beer.
Even here in New
York City, there
are 23 craft breweries
in New York City now.
Actually, I wrote a
piece for "Cranes" which
is going to come out in
September about all the craft
breweries in New York.
New York has been very
unfriendly to craft beer.
We were really the only ones to
succeed in the '80s and '90s.
There were about
20 or 30 startups
that failed during that
period in New York City, brew
pubs and craft breweries.
So the BA, the
Brewer's Association,
has been an incredible force
and power for craft brewers.
We now have a significant
clout in Washington
with the federal government,
we're a regulated industry.
You've got to be involved
in politics if you're
going to be in
the beer business,
and in every state government.
Home brewing actually is
legal now in 50 states.
I think Alabama was the last
one to legalize home brewing.
And that was through the efforts
of the Brewer's Association.
Today, you have
what I would call
the third generation
of craft brewers.
And back in the
'80s when we used
to go to the Craft Brewer's
Conference every year,
there might be 200
people or 300 people.
And back then it was like god,
there are 300 people here!
This year at the Craft
Brewer's Conference in Denver,
there were 10,000 people.
I had to work to find my
friends in the crowds.
It was quite amazing.
And the startups today,
unlike my generation
where we all had jobs and
careers before we started
breweries, these are young
people coming right out
of college with business
degrees or brewing
degrees who are going
right into this industry.
And it's a very
attractive industry.
It's a lot of fun.
It pays pretty well
now, a lot better
than it did when I started out.
When I started out sort of
taking a page from the tech
industry, we would
offer stock options
to people joining
Brooklyn Brewery
Because I mean I
was paying myself
$24,000 when we started in 1988.
And I had been making more
than twice that as a journalist
even back in the day.
But today, you could
make a good living
in the craft beer industry.
And actually, if you
get to a certain level
you can actually make
quite a bit of money.
So things have really changed.
And this third generation,
it's a mix of everything
that came before it.
You have all different
kind of business models.
And one of the people
I profile is this guy
with Kodiak Island
Brewing Company.
Kodiak Island is off
the coast of Alaska
over toward the Aleutians.
There are more bears on Kodiak
Island then there are people.
But this guy, Ben
Millstein and his wife
started this little brewery.
I think they're like 20,000
people on the island.
And their little
brewery has become
the center of social
life on that island.
The two senators from Alaska
have visited Kodiak island
to talk about how
great the brewery is.
And actually,
that's something I'm
very proud about with
Brooklyn Brewery.
And I think all the craft
breweries across the country
have had very positive
impacts on the communities
where they've started
because most of us
are very deeply involved
in the communities
where we're making beer.
If you're the person
making the beer
you have an interesting kind
of status in a community.
And it's something
I didn't really
understand until I
started doing it.
We don't do any advertising.
We do a little bit with "Edible"
and a few niche publications.
But mainly, we give away beer
to not for profit organizations
and causes we believe in.
And that's how I got
involved-- yeah, right, Mike.
That's how I got involved with
transportation alternatives,
and Prospect Park.
We give money to
literally hundreds
of organizations every year.
Beer and/or money.
And that's the way
we promote ourselves.
We do the same
thing in Stockholm
where we sell a lot of beer,
or London, or Columbus, Ohio.
We do this thing we
call the Brooklyn Mash.
It's a cultural festival
we do in 12 cities.
And it really celebrates
the creative culture
of the cities where
we're doing the events.
So we do food events, beer
events, comedy, literature,
music.
And all of it
using local talent.
We actually usually bring
a comedian from New York
to be part of the thing.
But it's mainly, it's kind of a
craft beer way of selling beer.
And actually, the
forward to my book
Is written by John Hickenlooper.
John started the Wynkoop
Brewery in Denver in 1988,
same year I started
Brooklyn Brewery.
Wynkoop was started
in Lower Down Town.
It was called LoDo.
And it was the
first sign of life
down in the LoDo for years.
That was like a
warehouse district
actually exactly like where
we started in Brooklyn
in the late 80s.
John eventually ran
for mayor of Denver
and became mayor of Denver.
And then he ran for
governor of Colorado,
and he's now
governor of Colorado.
So believe me, I have
no interest in politics.
But it's interesting
how he parlayed
his sort of revival of Denver
into a political career.
And actually, there's
been talk of him
being a vice
presidential candidate.
Colorado's a swing state
and he's a very liberal guy.
So don't be surprised if
he doesn't get paired up
with Hilary down the road here.
Also this new
generation, they're
following the same playbook
when it comes to marketing
and community involvement,
and all that kind of thing.
They're making all different
crazy kind of beers.
The styles that are being
explored are quite amazing.
I think Ninkasi
Brewery in Oregon
just sent some yeast
into outer space
as part of the space shuttle.
I'm not sure that's
really going to go
anywhere except up and down.
But the other day I did a
Reddit thing for two hours.
And I responded to 231 people.
And my favorite was
a guy from Brazil
who asked me if I had
tried the new beer made
with ants from Brazil.
And I told him I had not, and
I wasn't really eager to try.
There's a beer in
Iceland that is
made with malt that has
been smoked with sheep dung
because they don't have
too many trees in Iceland.
And actually, it's a
really good tasting beer.
And I couldn't really detect any
animal character to the beer.
And of course, Sam Calagione
has done incredible beers
based on ancient
Egypt and Babylon.
And beer's just an incredible,
wonderful, inexpensive
beverage.
And a lot of people
say to me, aren't you
guys kind of turning beer into
a snob beverage like wine?
And the answer is, no.
You can have the best beers
in the world in your cellar.
They're all accessible to you.
Whereas wine, the
CEOs of big companies
have cellars that no one
can even imagine owning.
So wine is a whole different
category than beer.
Let's see, have I
talked too long?
Yeah?
I'd be happy to answer
any questions you have.
A lot of people ask me
about the future of beer.
And I just want
to say that there
are 3,000 breweries
now in America.
When I started there
were fewer than 50.
There are 2000 breweries
in planning right now.
And I believe that America can
easily absorb 5,000 breweries.
Before prohibition there were
2,000 breweries in America.
And the population was
like, 40, 50 million.
The population now
it's 325 million.
We can handle this.
I think the future
of craft beer,
the successful
craft breweries are
going to be the breweries that
establish and maintain trust
with their customers.
You drink Brooklyn because
you live in New York,
and you like the beer, or
you've been to the brewery,
or we've given to your
favorite charity, or whatever.
But you have faith
in that brewery.
And I think that the
breweries that succeed
are going to be the
ones that maintain
that bond with the customers
because the customers,
the beer drinkers
have really made us.
We didn't brainwash them with
television advertising or radio
advertising.
They discovered us.
And they kind of
own us, and that's
a relationship that's very
precious for all craft brewers.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE: Let's see.
Before we take questions, just
a few quick announcements.
First, thanks to Alan Seals
and the authors of Google
team for making this talk
possible, a lot of hard work
behind the scenes.
Thanks to Steve for
sending us delicious beer.
It's been really hard having
that for the last month
at my desk and not
[INAUDIBLE] for all of you.
The books are for sale for
$10 in the back corner,
it's a subsidized price.
And if you have questions,
please use the mic right here.
Thank you.
Thanks, Mike.
AUDIENCE: How are
you doing Steve?
STEVE HINDY: Good.
AUDIENCE: So craft brewer
myself in Brooklyn,
Park Slope, backyard,
your old stomping ground.
STEVE HINDY: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: Shoutut to the
Brooklyn [INAUDIBLE].
It's my favorite.
I don't know if that's
[INAUDIBLE] Garrett's?
Quick question, so I'm
actually heading out
to the Ommegang for their
little camping session
that they do every year.
Been going there for years.
Chimay bought them
out a couple years.
STEVE HINDY: Not Chimay, Duvel.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm sorry.
Yes.
STEVE HINDY: Yeah,
Mort got that.
AUDIENCE: Right, there's sort
of a trend that's going on.
The same thing happened with
Goose Island bought out by,
Budweiser, and they were
bought out by InBev.
Where do you see that going?
It's almost like a
startup situation
that we have here where if
you come with a good beer
you get bought out or you
isolate, keep yourself
contained, maintain
just to your audience.
Where do you see the
future as far as that?
Because I know obviously
these agencies,
these bigger companies obviously
know the power of craft beer.
So if they see something, maybe
a spark, do they buy it up?
And do you get rich quick?
Just your thoughts on that.
STEVE HINDY: Yeah.
Well, I think some
people are going
to sell, no question about it.
John Hall from Goose Island
sold to Anheuser-Busch.
John started the same year
I did, I know him very well,
he and his son Greg.
But Greg told his
dad he really didn't
want to do this for
the rest of his life.
So John is, at the time he sold,
I think he was 69 years old.
And what you're going to do?
He cashed out.
I have no problem with that.
I think for the big guys,
craft beer is a real dilemma.
MillerCoors makes Blue Moon.
AB has Shock Top, now
they have Goose Island.
They bought Bluepoint out on
Long Island a couple of months
ago.
They're going to play in our
segment, no question about it.
I don't think they can
dominate our segment the way
they dominated mainstream beer.
Also, I think the more they
play in our segment the more
they undercut their big brands.
When I started in
business, imports
were 3% of the US market.
The other 97% was
national brands.
Today, imports are 13%.
Craft beer is like
more than 10%,
and MillerCoors
and InBev are 74%.
So arguably, we've pushed
them back from 97% to 74%.
And it's going to
continue, I think.
They're going to
buy craft breweries.
There's a guy I know
who's on the board,
I actually I know a
lot of the big brewers
because I've been on their
board for several years.
They have one token small guy
on the board, and it's been me.
One of the guys on the
board of MillerCoors,
I was having an argument
with him one day.
I said, Fritz, Blue
Moon's a big brand.
He said, Steve, it doesn't
move the needle for us.
It doesn't matter.
And that's kind of the
way they look at things.
AB InBev last year sold
323 million barrels of beer
worldwide.
SAB Miller sold 210 million,
Molson Coors sold 51 million.
The whole craft beer segment
is about 20 million barrels.
So we have a long,
long way to go,
and I think there are going
to be many years of growth.
And I think the most
successful companies are
going to be the ones
that stay independent,
and that's what were
determined to do.
My business partners will
be the next generation
of Brooklyn Brewery.
We're not going to sell out.
AUDIENCE: Good to hear.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming,
appreciate the talk a lot.
I had the good fortunes
of being in Denmark
earlier this year,
and really had
a blast at Mikkeller
& Friends and tasted
some phenomenal stuff.
I just wanted to get your
view on internationally,
what's the place to watch?
Where do you think a
lot of the cool stuff
is happening outside the US?
STEVE HINDY: Well,
we're, I think,
the biggest exporter
of craft beer.
Last year, of our 220,000
barrels, about 28% was export.
And our biggest markets
are Scandinavia and the UK.
We're doing really
well in France.
It's beginning to
happen in Brazil
in a big way, and Australia.
And we just opened a brewery
in Stockholm with Carlsberg.
It's a partnership
called New Carnegie
Brewery by Brooklyn Brewery.
If you go to Stockholm
you have to go visit.
It's got a restaurant,
it's really cool.
You can get there
by a ferry boat.
So there's a lot of really cool
stuff happening in Scandinavia.
We just did our Mash
Festival in London last week,
and I was amazed.
London now, there are 69
craft breweries in London.
When I was in London in
the '90s when we first
started selling there, most
of the bars were tied houses.
So they're controlled
by the breweries.
There were only a handful
of free houses, which
is a bar that can buy from
anybody that want to buy from.
Now there are
countless free houses,
and they're carrying American
craft beer and British craft
beer.
And a lot of the tide
houses are buying their way
out of the relationships they
have with the big breweries
so they can carry craft beers.
So we did an event at the
Camden Town Brewery, which
is, I think Meantime
in Camden are
the two biggest among
the London breweries.
You've got to go see this
place is if you're in London.
A lot of the breweries are done
where the cheapest rent is, not
surprised.
They're done in these arches
under the rail trestles.
Camden is unbelievable.
They have eight arches.
A lot of the arches
you can't connect them
because they're structural.
But Camden, you can.
So they have all these arches.
They have fermenters
out in this alley kind
of under the catwalks
for the trains.
I don't know how they ever
got approval for this.
And actually, the
guy from Camden
said, well, what they
don't know won't hurt them.
And across the street now,
there are apartment buildings.
But when they opened,
it's kind of like what
happened to us in Brooklyn.
When they opened there
was nothing there.
It was like a big, empty
lot across the street.
So I think there's really
cool stuff happening
in Denmark, in
Sweden, in Norway.
It's going to happen everywhere.
And I'm sure the
Brazilians will come up
with a lot besides ant beer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hey, thank
so much for coming out.
Just a quick question regarding
actually the Reddit AMA thread.
I read through that, and your
number one piece of life advice
was, don't do business
with assholes.
STEVE HINDY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Followed up by a
couple separation agreements,
and stuff.
Is there personal
anecdotes or situations
that happened that made
this your number one
piece of life advice?
STEVE HINDY: Well, with Reddit
you've got to be on it, right?
Yeah.
Milton Glaser is my designer.
Milton's the guy who did
the "I love New York"
logo, very wise man.
Milton's 85 years old now.
We've been working
together for 30 years.
And Milton is the one
who basically gave me
that bit of advice
many, many years ago.
Because he doesn't design
for people he doesn't like.
And it's been
pretty good advice.
There have been cases
where we have done business
with people who we
didn't really like,
and usually it ends badly.
Like there are a
lot of big retailers
who basically will
say to me, look,
I'll pay you this for your beer.
Like your keg price is $100,
we're going to pay $75.
And your face, you
know that you're
selling to hundreds
of people for $100,
and here's this jerk
telling you, no, I'm
going to buy for $75.
And your best customers
are paying the full price.
Now, a lot of brewers will
deal with people like that.
I don't.
I couldn't live with myself
if I'm selling to my better
customers at this
higher price and I'm
giving this jerk
a price for $75.
And I've seen it happen.
It doesn't pay off
in the long run.
So anyway, not to get
carried away with that,
I think it's pretty good advice.
Maybe unavoidable
sometimes, but-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
Thanks for coming in.
I actually had a follow up
question on one of early ones,
breweries were using areas
where the rent's fairly low.
STEVE HINDY: With what?
AUDIENCE: How
breweries tend to go
for areas with the
really low rents.
STEVE HINDY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think
my parents would
be worried for me if I
started a brewery there.
Do you know people, does
it usually work out OK
for the brewers?
STEVE HINDY: Well.
our first warehouse
was in Bushwick
off Bushwick avenue one Meserole
in an old brewery building.
And truck drivers would not
come in there after dark,
these big truck
drivers would call in
and say, we'll be
there in the morning.
We're not coming this afternoon.
And most mornings when
we came in to open up,
there were junkies across the
street in this little needle
park.
But I had been in Beirut and
Baghdad, so I could handle it.
But it's true.
All the craft
brewers in London are
in very dicey kind
of neighborhoods.
I did an event in DC, part
of our Mash thing recently,
and it was in a really
skeezy part of the DC.
So that's kind of the way it is.
You're manufacturing,
you can't afford
to pay $20 a foot for your rent.
You've got to go
where it's $3 a foot.
But my parents were
thrilled that I
had come back to the USA.
Actually, my father did
not understand or believe
in journalism.
He was thrilled when I said
I'm going into business.
It was like, finally!
You'll make some money
with that Cornell degree.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STEVE HINDY: You're welcome.
Well, thank you all very much.
I'd be happy to sign
some books if you want.
And if you have further
questions, have a nice day.
Do you want to know
about the beers?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
STEVE HINDY: So that wheat beer,
Brooklyn Green Market Wheat,
we do that with the GrowNYC,
the not for profit company that
runs all the 53 farmers
markets in New York City.
And it's made with
70% local ingredients.
So the grain is grown
in upstate New York.
There's some barley from
Massachusetts in that beer.
And we're committed
to growing that brand.
So we had a wheat beer called
Brooklyner Weisse which
we got rid of, and that's
our main wheat beer now.
And part of the proceeds
goes to the GrowNYC
of every bottle we
sell of that beer.
And they sell it at
the green markets,
and they make all the
retail markup on that.
So it's our way of
supporting farmers,
and we're hoping
the farmers upstate
are going to grow
more grain every year
so we can produce
more of this beer
and take it beyond
New York state.
The other beer,
Brooklyn Cuvee Noir,
is a strong stout that we
age in bourbon barrels.
It's also got a little
sweet orange peel in it.
It's aged in bourbon barrels
for more than six months,
and it's part of our
barrel age series.
Every quarter we have a
different bottled beer
that's aged in bourbon barrels,
or wine barrels, or whatever.
I think the last one was Wild
Streak, which is basically
a version of a local one
aged in bourbon barrels
and finished off with
a Brettanomyces yeast.
Brettanomyces creates
sour flavors in the beer.
So that's part of our
innovation series of beers.
We don't really call it that,
but that's what it's all about.
Actually, we just took a big
warehouse in the Navy Yard
to expand our
barrel aging program
because the little warehouse
we had over near the brewery,
we outgrew it.
So you're going to see some
exciting beers come out
of that series.
And I hope you liked Cuvee Noir.
And if you go on
our website, there's
a great video that
Garrett did, Garrett,
our brewmaster about Cuvee Noir.
And it's kind of like a
Dashiell Hammett sort of scene.
Garrett's a great performer
as well as a great brewer.
Thank you very much.